all right the emmys were on sunday um
i didn't know this was happening of
course until i saw the outrage on
twitter there's always there always has
to be some sort of awards outrage that
comes out of these things and this time
sometimes the outrage is sort of fun to
talk about the will smith thing i mean
that was a classic right that was that
was act that was actually an enjoyable
awards show related
outrage that was
enjoyable to talk about and entertaining
um the one from the emmys this is a
little disappointing it doesn't quite
live up to the hype so jimmy kimmel did
a bit
i don't know all the background on this
i don't care the bit i guess is that he
he was up presenting the award for some
category
and uh he pretended to pass out
for some reason on the stage
and then
they announced the winner and it was an
actress who was black
and kimmel kept lying there
still pretending to be passed out even
as she came up to give her acceptance
speech let's uh
let's watch a little bit of that moment
quinter brunson elementary
[Music]
[Music]
jimmy wake up i won
jimmy
okay hold up
um
um
my goodness
okay and then she uh could she just
gives her acceptance speech with the guy
lying there it is it's awkward
and weird
uh and that's really all that can be
said about it but but but
as always social media and the news
media
they're not satisfied to just say that
because there's there are racial
dynamics here you know it's jimmy
kimmel's a white guy this actress is a
black woman
and so now they're making it racial it's
all these headlines saying that it was
racist it was racist for jimmy kimmel to
to steal the woman's shine like that you
know there's all these posts on social
media white men are always doing this
damn white men yeah there's something
white men always do they white men are
constantly
lying on award show stages while people
are trying to give uh give their
acceptance speeches it's just it's a
thing we always do it's part of our
culture
now
um
this just shows again the problem with
racializing everything
because
it's guaranteed that you're going to
miss the point
and also you end up distracting from
valid criticisms
in this case this is like a small
example of it but there's a very valid
criticism you could make of jimmy kimmel
he's he's an ass i mean jimmy kimmel is
a jerk he's a he's a bad person
and he's arrogant and self-centered and
yeah he wanted to make this moment about
him i'd be annoyed too if i if i'm up
there giving
my acceptance speech when i win an emmy
and there's just some jerk laying on the
ground you know because he thought of
this bad comedy bit and he's he's doing
it in the middle of my i'd be annoyed by
that
i'd you know just like kick him in the
ribs or something make him move
but it's not racial like the idea that
he did it because she's a black woman
he said to himself oh this is a black
woman i gotta yeah
i gotta do what i can to intrude here
he's absurd
although it is kind of uh it is kind of
funny that
jimmy kimmel
to this point you know with the racial
outrage brigade out there searching for
racism wherever they can find it often
landing in places where the racism ends
up being imaginary and invisible you
know they're over at byu searching for
an invisible racist who silently shouted
the n-word meanwhile jimmy kimmel
has been a late-night network tv host
for years now
and there are tons of videos of him out
there in blackface this is something
this guy did all the time back in the in
the 90s
he was constantly in blackface
and somehow he has
escaped criticism for that
so it'd be kind of funny if this is what
brings him down like this is the racial
controversy that brings him down where
he wasn't even actually being racist
it's a little bit of the you know the
the o.j simpson thing where they
couldn't get him from murder so instead
they get him for stealing his own
merchandise back or whatever it was so
baits it's kind of same thing here they
didn't get jimmy kimmel for the
blackface so they're gonna get him for
this instead
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did be sure
to subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts